does Jeff reitman I don't know where
Adam is but we're bringing you another
nerd wars this one's coming from hello
Master Chief
it's Boba Fett versus Deadpool I will do
the opening gambit right here
there's no way that Boba Fett could stop
Deadpool simply because I'm just gonna
put this out right now Deadpool has a
healing factor like you can decapitate
Deadpool he has a healing factor you
know how many times you've used that
argument easy you can pull every week no
this is the first time a healing factor
doors got a healing factor I never said
that
Daredevils got a healing ever said that
Superman's got a healing pheasant
Wolverines got a healing factor that one
was right here's the thing Deadpool has
been liquidized
numerous times actually melted down and
turned into liquid still regroups
reforms and comes back for more I got
one word for you what's that
mandalorian it isn't that an 18th
century musical instrument got
Mandalorian armor he just kicked some
ass he's the son of Jango Fett so
basically you're saying that because
it's dads badass Boba Fett can beat him
up yeah I got no it's a badass breeding
program Oh Boba Fett has to do is
collect that liquid and tiny little
container and put it on slave one and
just shoot around the space and 20 years
later Deadpool would come back and kick
his ass luckily they're both mortal so
they'd be dead 20 years from now sorry
I'll cool people die before the hit
senior citizen sorry dude Deadpool with
his healing factor means that he really
doesn't age same as Wolverine blam
another point for Deadpool healing
factor has nothing to do with aging yes
it does no League does that he keeps
healing no terior rating I'm gonna edit
it so I win yeah
yeah you see it's all one-sided like
right now right now here's gonna be the
worst picture you can imagine of
Deadpool and now here's a really
kick-ass picture of Boba Fett
yeah well that's how the editing see the
thing is you can't find a non kick-ass
picture of Boba Fett because he's that
badass
pack that pool going around get okay he
came out of the Sarlacc pit whatever he
survived the Sarlacc really we're gonna
play that game oh yeah so yeah he did
die in the starlight pit until died
until 20 years later he did when George
Lucas decided that he should live
because he's marketable no that was in
the books whatever you know you know
what you can do Meadows there's a whole
series of novels of Boba Fett I'm gonna
I'm gonna become the most unpopular guy
on this website by saying those novels
suck yeah once you go read a dumbass
Deadpool comic here's here's here's a
little point he's a trained assassin so
is boba fett no he's a bounty hunter
Boba Fett's got years and yet he has to
deal with far creepier people than
Deadpool ever has to do
Deadpool's an assassin Boba Fett's a
bounty hunter and I have watched Dog the
Bounty Hunter and there's nothing
intimidating about a bounty hunter
oh that mullet what are you talking
about the the most intimidating thing
about Dawg are happy wife's nails his
wife's nails exactly and the boobs
they're like Wolverines claws yeah maybe
if Boba Fett has a fat big-breasted wife
The Dog the Bounty Hunter has I'd give
the point how do we know he doesn't they
really don't go over you know how many
times Deadpool's died zero no one can't
kill both head
no no they did kill Boba Fett no they
didn't yeah they did they threw him in a
star like Pitney came out and then there
was and then there was a book oh so
you're gonna say oh there was that first
book Deadpool was in and then there was
another book that doesn't matter because
I'm declaring for my argument that those
books don't matter if you walk we could
find some fan pics of Deadpool banging
Princess Leia doesn't mean it happened
tell us how much ass
Deadpool would kick or how badass Boba
Fett is because he's the most badass
boat Johnny hunter in the universe just
like me because use your weapons
[Music]